prime minister boris johnson has just
tweeted out a video
let's just have a listen it's like so
many hundreds of thousands of
other people across the country i've
been pinned i've been asked to
self-isolate by the test trace and
isolate system
after i've been in contact with somebody
who has covered
in this case of course the health
secretary sajid javid and
we did look briefly at the idea of
us taking part in the the pilot scheme
which
allows people to test daily but i think
it's far more important that everybody
sticks to the same rules and that's why
i'm going to be self-isolating until the
26th of july monday
the 26th of july and i really i know how
frustrated it all is but i really do
urge
everybody to stick with the program
and take the appropriate course of
action when you're asked
to do say do so by nhs test and trace
and
the reason for that is we're going
tomorrow into step four we're
doing a big opening up and that's quite
right if we don't do it now
then we'll be opening up in the the
autumn the winter months when the virus
has the advantage of the
of the cold weather we lose the uh the
precious
fire break that we get with the school
holidays we don't
do it now we've got to ask ourselves
when will we ever do it so
this is the right moment but we've got
to do it
cautiously we've got to remember that
this virus is
sadly still out there cases are rising
we can see the
extreme contagiousness of the of the
delta variant but we have this
immense uh consolation and uh
and satisfaction that the there is no
doubt at all
that the vaccine program the massive
vaccination program has
very severely weakened the link between
infection and hospitalization and
between
uh between infection and serious illness
and death and that is the vital thing so
please please please be cautious uh go
forward
tomorrow into uh the next step with
all the right prudence and respect for
other people and the the risks that the
disease continues
to present and above all please please
please
when you're asked to get that second
jab get your jab please come forward and
do it
thank you all very much the prime
minister who posted that video on his
twitter page
just a few minutes ago